well right now the United States is by
far the world's top funder of the World
Health Organization when give the
organization about 58 million dollars
every year that's double what any other
country donates for some reason but for
the organization's leaders there's only
one country that matters and it's not us
it's China right now Taiwan is battling
coronavirus but they are denied
membership in the World Health
Organization they can't even have
observer status why is that people are
dying but the World Health Organization
refuses to protect them why do you think
that is because China objects to anyone
acknowledging the Taiwan is a nation
from the beginning World Health
Organization officials have praised
China's response to coronavirus they've
repeated that country's lies as fact to
the rest of the world
initially China claimed the chrono virus
could not be transmitted from person to
person
even though doctors in Wuhan knew
otherwise and it was obviously untrue
the World Health Organization though
told that lied to the world and that
hindered global preparation to contain
the virus they made it worse not better
and then the World Health Organization
praised China for its transparency a
cruel joke as those lives have been
exposed the World Health Organization
subservience to their masters in Beijing
has only become more obvious more naked
on Saturday a Hong Kong television
station air in an interview with the
World Health Organization assistant
director called Bruce Aylward he's a
Canadian we want to show you this whole
thing we hope you'll watch carefully
because it tells you everything about
where this world is going and why you
should be really nervous about the
government of China watch this would the
WTO
consider Taiwan's membership
hello I couldn't hear your question yeah
let me let me repeat the question move
to another one right I think it's
because I'm I'm actually curious I'm
talking about Taiwan as well on Taiwan's
case we decided to give dr. outward
another call to follow up and I just
want to see if you can comment a bit on
how Chi Hwan has done so far in terms of
containing the virus well we've already
talked about China and you know when you
look across all the different areas of
China they've actually all done quite a
good job so with that I'd like to thank
you very much for inviting us to
participate and and good luck as you go
forward with the battle in Hong Kong in
the middle of the global pandemic
they're refusing to help a country
because China told them not to and then
the World Health Organization which
represents all of us which we pay for
more than any other country is boldly
without shame repeating Chinese
government propaganda the man you just
saw Bruce Alward by the way wasn't just
caught in a bad moment over Skype here's
another clip of him sucking up to the
government of China to the people of who
it is recognized to the world's in your
debt hopefully we'll have a chance to
thank the people who had for the role
that they played in it it's it's beyond
disgusting
it's scary Gordon Chang is the author of
the coming collapse of China and he
joins us tonight Gordon you've been on
this topic for such a long time does it
surprise you that the World Health
Organization was normal-people me look
at and think you know they're keeping
the world safe from pandemics that
they're actually acting as a spokesman
for the government of China does that
surprise you
well this has been going on for some
time tucker and there have been a number
of other things that we've got to be
concerned about so it's not just bruce
albert who by the way said that he had
absolutely no reason to question china's
numbers it's also dr. Ted Rose who's the
director-general
it's the number one guy in late January
10th Rose gave an interview to China's
state media saying that Beijing's
response was admirable should be
emulated by the rest of the world and
then he said it all showed the
superiority of China's socialist system
well China has a totalitarian system and
really what he was doing was attacking
democracy on behalf of Beijing so this
is really despicable across the board I
mean this really matters this isn't like
NBA players kowtow to the Chinese
government we're in the middle of a
pandemic this is the World Health
Organization why is nobody where is Bill
Gates who's the single largest
individual funder why isn't he saying
anything why isn't Google saying
anything why aren't our leaders saying
anything about this no you're absolutely
right this is dangerous because for the
last 10 days of January and for the
first 1015 days of February the World
Health Organization was parroting
Beijing's line that no country should
enact travel restrictions on China and
that's because there were no travel
restrictions or very few of them you got
it states being an exception what
happened was this virus spread even
farther behind around China's borders so
what w-h-o is done was it actually
helped spread the corona virus around
the world and it did it on behalf of
Beijing it's just it's just beyond
belief so it's hard to believe those
words are true but they are true Gordon
Cheng thank you for that Thank You
Tucker